Chairman Kim and I will meet again on
February 27th and 28th in Vietnam the
time and place is set for a second Kim
Trump summit both held last year's
meeting in Singapore a success so why
choose Vietnam for round 2 in its recent
history Vietnam has had a lot in common
with North Korea it's also a one-party
communist state one that's been ruled
with an iron fist its regime reinforced
by propaganda and personality cults and
in the past had seen open hostility to
Western culture and influence it's been
isolated and an international pariah
but since 1986 Vietnam has taken a
different path with reforms that have
opened it up to foreign business in a
remarkable turnaround it's gone from
basket case to one of Asia's
fastest-growing economies could Vietnam
style change be a good fit for North
Korea Vietnam Vietnam starting point
before the reform is similar to North
Korea's now there are many things that
had to be changed fundamentally when you
switch from a centralized economy to a
market economy the important thing is to
have a broad and far vision and to
reform thoroughly and completely major
Tetley
Viet Nam's reforms have seen its per
capita income saw almost fivefold but
Hanoi hasn't traded prosperity for
democracy here the Communist Party
remains firmly in power keeping a tight
lid on free speech and political dissent
but the social transformation is there
to see the site of skateboarders in
front of lenin statue in hanoi would
have been unimaginable not long ago
compare that to today's Pyongyang where
public life is carefully controlled and
North Korean leaders are still revered
as deities Vietnam has rebuilt ties with
its former foe the United States perhaps
a role model for North Korea to also
normalize a troubled relationship for
more we are joined from Manila by boom
in Hong he's an associate professor and
economic analyst at Singapore's Lee Kuan
Yew School of Public Policy professor vu
my first question to you by Vietnam as a
choice of venue for this meeting I think
they are three clear reasons the first
one choosing Vietnam is very important
gesture because they're both our leaders
would like to demonstrate to the world
that they are willing to make
breakthrough this season sending an
enemy to a friend the second reason
actually it's so that the meeting will
be very outcome oriented so not only
symbolic but also how come
oriented because Vietnam is actually
example example about your children
thermoset and a big reward so from a
very isolated country now Vietnam is
become one of the most globally
integrated into the wall and if I can
just take up on that point Vietnam has
certainly managed this transformation
but is this really the transformation is
this really the change that North Korea
wants I think so because in terms of
size because II am do not have any
superstar just try to speak now how to
you know make the country better off and
learning along the way
I am very relevant and actually the best
way to be legitimacy of the political
system so you can maintain political
stability why actually giving people
more and more power over the road and
people always see that you know next
year better than last year everything
Environmental Protection - economic
performance and even political freedom
in some way of course you are as low
level but we see a significant
improvement every year just on that
point about political stability
professor who you have held positions in
the Vietnamese government how
sustainable do you think is this
combination of one-party rule with
political stability and liberalized
economic policies how sustainable is
this for any economy I think it's by the
sustainable way in the country still
poor because you know according to
theory and empirical study if you have
income lower than ten thousand level
somehow we have to accept you know
one-party system it's better for you to
focus on the strategic issue like a
building infrastructure attracting
foreign investment and probably
promoting private sector so that
actually once the country become
prosperous and treated people will have
more choices on their actually political
freedom
professor woman come from the Lee Kuan
Yew School of Public Policy thank you
very much was being to us
you